how much time would Brad Pitt spend in  the makeup chair for this five hours a  day crazy right well very soon this will  become a thing of the past Disney has  just made re-aging much easier and  cheaper the company created a neural  network that takes seconds to re-age  someone's face but what does the typical  re-aging process look like usually the  production team uses 3D scanning and  modeling it takes weeks sometimes even  longer Fran fully automates the process  by using a large database of randomly  generated synthetic faces at different  ages it bypasses the need to find  thousands of pictures of real people  with the same facial expression stance  lighting and background this technology  would definitely blow Snapchat's aging  filter out of the water but will Disney  share Fran with the public in the future  we'll be the first to update you on that  just don't forget to subscribe